[Music]
when I feel depressed like loads of
people I say I feel down right and as I
was learning about the causes of
depression anxiety feel a bit lost
connections I started to realize I don't
think that's the metaphor this is
amazing professor at Stanford called
Robert Sapolsky who in his early 20s
went to live with a troop of baboons in
Kenya and it was his job to figure out
when our baboons most stressed out his
job was to hit them with little
tranquilizer darts and then take a blood
test and measure something called
cortisol which is a hormone that baboons
and us release when we're stressed and
baboons live in this hierarchy so the
females don't interestingly but the men
live in a very strict hierarchy so if
there's 30 men number one knows he's
above number two number two knows is
above number three number 12 knows about
number 13 and that really determines a
lot it determines who you get to have
sex with it determines what you get to
eat it determines whether you get to sit
in the shade or you're pushed out into
the heat yeah it's a really really
significant where you are in the in the
hierarchy and what professor Sapolsky
found is baboons are most stressed in
two situations one is when their status
is insecure so if you're the top guy and
someone circling which comes for you you
will be massively stressed and the other
situation is when you feel you're at the
bottom of a hierarchy you're you're
you're you know you've been kind of
humiliated and what what professor
Sapolsky found which i think is really
noticed and then it was later developed
by other scientists is when you feel
you've been pushed to the bottom what
you do is you show something called its
submission gesture so you baboon z' will
raise as I say you assume nobody's are
watching this maybe they are and a
baboon will put its body down physically
it'll put its head down it will put its
bottom in the air and it will cover its
head so it's clearly since to be
communicating just leave me alone you've
beaten me okay you've beaten me and what
lots of scientists all scream develop
people like Professor Paul Gilbert in
Britain and professor Kate Pickett
impressive Richard Wilkinson also in
Britain have really developed to this
idea that actually what human depression
is in part not entirely but in part is a
form of us
mission gesture it's a way of saying I
can't cope with this anymore right
particularly Bree feel they've been
pushed to the bottom of hierarchies all
who still remember the other stressful
situations when you feel your status is
insecure it's a way of just going okay
okay I retreat I don't want this fight
anymore you beaten me it's a kind of
very strong evolutionary impulse where
you feel you're under attack
so just submit in the hope that the
stress and anxiety will then go away
that the sources of the stress and
anxiety will then go away
and one things that's so important Kate
will consider it sorry Kate Pickett and
Richard Wilkinson really developed this
is they've shown so as inequality grows
depression and anxiety grow they've
shown this as very robust effect right
this helps us to explain it if you live
in Norway your status is relatively
secure right no one's that high no one's
that low movement between where you are
is not it's so extreme if you live in
the United States especially today which
is we're now at the greatest levels of
inequality since the 1920s there's a few
people at the very top there's a kind of
precarious middle and there's a huge and
swelling bottom right so you've got you
can see why in the United States you've
got more people who'd be showing a
submission gesture who'd be like aha
Jesus I've been beaten then there would
be in Norway this is why inequality is
one of the drivers of depression and
anxiety and why dealing with inequality
reduces inequality and anxiety it's one
the things that really shocked me
actually was looking at in the United
States the group with the lowest
depression by far as the Amish so I went
and spent time with an Amish community
the Amish live in these homogeneous
groups which are incredibly equal the
richest Amish is as worth as much as the
poorest Amish right they're not showing
some submission gestures in the same way
because no they don't that there's a lot
wrong with the Amish don't get me wrong
I'm not suggesting mass conversion to
the Amish I'm a gay man believe me I'm
not but but we can learn from the fact
that in these highly equal and
homogeneous groups you don't have that
that extreme status stress now that will
go as far as the Amish do but we moving
closer to it would be one of the factors
that would reduce depression and anxiety
[Music]